the graph below contains the rectangle a
b c p
draw the image of abcp under a dilation
whose center is at p
and a scale factor is
is one and two thirds what are the
lengths of the side a b
and its image
so we're going to do a dilation centered
at p
so for centering a dilation at p that
means that every other point is going
and its scale factor is one and
two-thirds that means once we scale once
we perform the dilute once we perform
the dilation
every point is going to be one and
two-thirds times as far away from p
well p is zero away from p so p is still
going to be its image is still going to
be at p so let's put that point right
over there
now
point c is going to be one and two
thirds times far as far as it is right
now so let's see right now it is six
away it's at negative three and p is or
it's y its x coordinate is the same but
in the y direction p is at 3 c is at
negative 3. so it's 6 less we want to be
one and two thirds times as far away so
what's one and two thirds of six
well two thirds of six is four so it's
going to be
six plus four is going to be you're
going to be 10 away so 3 minus 10 that
gets us to negative 7 so that gets us
right over there
now point a
right now it is three more in the
horizontal direction than point p's x
coordinate so we're we want to go one
and two thirds as far so what is one and
two thirds times three well that's going
to be 3 plus 2 3 of 3 which is another
2. so that's going to be 5. so we're
going to get right over there and then
we can complete the rectangle and notice
point b
is now 1 and 2 3 times as far in the
horizontal direction it was 3 away in
the horizontal direction now it is 5
away from p's x coordinate and in the
vertical direction in the vertical
direction in the y direction it was 6
below p's y coordinate now it is 1 2
two-thirds times as far it is 10 below
it is 10 below p's y-coordinate
so that's to answer these questions this
the length of segment a b
a b
well we already saw that that is we're
going from 3 to negative three that is
six units long
that is six units long and it's image
well it's one one and two thirds as long
we see it over here going from three to
negative seven three minus negative
seven is ten
it is ten
units
long
we got it right